salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien je suis hyper content de vous
retrouver pour cette vidéo parce que je
pense que ça fait longtemps je voulais
la faire et j'en ai vraiment ressenti le
besoin en juin dernier quand j'étais en
syrie et je tournais mon dernier
documentaire pour la plate forme brute x
qui s'appelle stade noir et qui vient de
sortir vous met tout de suite le teaser
pour vous voyez de quoi ça parle
viens d'arriver houston doha car
c'est un endroit qui a été transformée
pendant leur règne de dèche en prison
[Musique]
brad hamasyan marocaine
car maurice
[Musique]
encore une trace de neige
je touche il toilette question dessous
du stade ont été transformées en
cellules
ce documentaire c'est sûrement mon
dernier reportage sur l'état islamique
et dans cette vidéo je vais essayer de
vous expliquer pourquoi
[Musique]
pour bien comprendre l'histoire que je
vais vous raconter il faut forcément je
vous parle du contexte au début de la
guerre en syrie et du danger d'être
reporter dans cette région à ce moment
là bien avant que moi j'y ait vous
préviens c'est pas un sujet facile mais
je pense que ça va vous intéresser donc
accrochez-vous en 2011 au début de la
révolution dans le pays j'étais tout
jeune j'avais 21 ans et j'étais en train
de finir mais c'est une de journalisme
je savais déjà que voulait travailler
plus tard en zone de conflit donc je
suivais de très près ce qui se passait
là bas et c'est rapidement devenu une
des guerres les plus violentes de
l'histoire contemporaine d'abord pour
les populations civiles mais aussi pour
les journalistes syriens et étrangers et
dès janvier 2012 un grand reporter
français a été tué à homs il s'appelait
gilles jacquier
un mois plus tard dans la même ville
c'est le photographe rémi o'shea qui
meurent à cause d'un missile avec une
autre reporter américaine très connu qui
s'appelait marie colville c'était que
des reporters confirmé je suivais leur
travail donc ça m'avait marqué
aujourd'hui la plupart des enquêtes
sérieuses qui ont été menés sur leur
mort disent que c'est le régime de
bachar al-assad qui a commandité ces
attaques pourtant pendant longtemps le
régime déclaré que c'était le camp d'en
face l'armée syrienne libre son
principal opposant au début de la
révolution qui avait lancé ses missiles
si je vous parle de ça c'est pour vous
planter un peu le décor et vous montrer
à quel point les journalistes peuvent
être des cibles stratégiques dans les
zones de conflit et ça pour plein de
raisons différentes la première étant
évidemment pour empêcher d'informer sur
les crimes de guerre mais aussi parce
qu'on peut instrumentaliser la mort d'un
reporter pour affaiblir un adversaire et
ça quand je vais sur le terrain gelé
toujours en tête je me demande à chaque
fois à quel point je peux être utilisé
ou ma mort peut être utilisé par les
différents belligérants pour faire de la
propagande il faut aussi savoir qu'on
est des cibles de choix pour les
enlèvement parce qu'on peut servir de
monnaie d'échangé pour faire libérer des
prisonniers dans certains cas où pour
récupérer des grosses sommes d'argent
dans l'autre et c'est ce point qui
m'amène à l'état islamique entre la fin
de l'année 2012 et le courant de l'année
2013 plusieurs journalistes français et
étrangers sont capturées par
l'organisation terroriste en syrie les
français sont libérés après presque un
an de détention un en enfer mais
beaucoup d'autres n'ont pas cette chance
et sont assassinés je pense évidemment à
james foley et stevenson of thé reporter
américain
il y aura aussi un peu plus tard ken
gigottos un journaliste japonais
les vidéos de leur décapitation ont fait
le tour du monde pour servir la
propagande de terreur de l'état
islamique
et ça a marché parce que pendant une
longue période il y avait quasiment plus
aucune rédaction française qui voulait
envoyer des reporters sur le terrain
parce qu'il trouvait que c'était
beaucoup trop risqué la grande majorité
des journalistes étaient terrorisés à
l'idée d'essayer de retourner là bas et
je me rappelle de conversation à
l'époque avec des collègues
vraiment on était tous là à se dire il
ya plus de chances qu'on faut enlever ou
qu'on se fasse buts et qu' on puisse
ramener en fait les images de nos
reportages je précise aussi parce que
c'est hyper important que la plupart des
journalistes qui ont été tués par l'état
islamique là bas c'était des syriens et
des irakiens
parmi les reporters français qui ont été
pris en otage à cette époque là il y en
a un que j'ai rencontré complètement par
hasard quelques mois seulement après sa
libération dans un stage avec l'armée il
s'appelle edward alias en gros pendant
une semaine on était avec des commandos
pour apprendre les rudiments de survie
pour manipuler certaines armes et mieux
comprendre leur fonctionnement mais
aussi pour avoir des retours
d'expérience de militaires qui avaient
déjà été déployés en zone de conflit
certains avaient travaillé sur le
terrain avec des journalistes et ça
c'était pas forcément très bien passé
donc l'idée c'était aussi de se parler
pour voir comment on peut bosser
ensemble d'une façon qui met pas en
danger la vie des uns et des autres et
pendant ce stage on était une quinzaine
de reporter et on s'apprêtait tous plus
ou moins soit à partir dans une zone de
conflit soit on travaillait
régulièrement dans des actions des
crises humanitaires dans des endroits
difficiles et parmi eux il y avait ce
photographe de 23 ans edouard il ya ce
qui était le plus jeune du groupe avec
moi et du coup il nous avait raconté
l'enfer de ce qu'il avait vécu pendant
sa prise d'otage la torture physique
psychologique et je sais que ça m'avait
énormément marqué parce que on avait le
même âge et je me demandais forcément
comment moi j'aurais vécu une situation
pareille même si en vrai c'est
impossible de se mettre à la place d'un
autre âge c'est aussi à cette période là
qui a les attentats en france contre
charlie hebdo à montrouge et à l'hyper
cacher
et ça c'est mon premier contact direct
avec le terrorisme c'était à paris
devant libère cacher parce que j'y étais
pour filmer l'assaut du raid et de la br
i j'étais arrivé sur place très vite
avant que les forces de police ne boucle
complètement le quartier et j'étais
monté dans un immeuble je précise que je
ne filmaient pas du tout la scène en
direct le reportage que j'ai tourné a
été diffusée après pour ne pas mettre en
danger ni les otages ni l'opération de
police et du coup entre ce qui se
passait dans mon pays et au moyen-orient
en irak et en syrie clairement je
trouvais ça beaucoup trop dangereux
d'aller sur place à ce moment là en fait
donc j'ai continué à enquêter à distance
et à préparer le terrain pour pouvoir y
aller un jour et ce n'est qu'en juin
2017 environ deux ans et demi plus tard
que je me décide enfin à aller sur place
parce que la coalition gagne du terrain
et récupère des territoires à l'état
islamique en irak et en syrie
je me suis rendu là-bas pour réaliser
deux documentaires le premier sur les
charniers du groupe terroriste un
charnier c'est une fausse un trou on
entasse des cadavres sans leur donner de
sépulture décente et le second sur les
hôpitaux de guerre de la bataille de
mossoul le jour où j'ai atterri en irak
le 19 juin 2017 deux reporters français
stéphane villeneuve et véronic robert
ainsi que leur fixeur irakien bakhtiar
haddad sont morts sur la ligne de front
de la bataille de mossoul en marchant
sur une mine à notre journaliste était
avec eux à ce moment-là il s'appelle
samuel fort et il a été blessé mais il a
survécu et samuel c'était un reporter
qui était au stage de l'armée trois ans
plus tôt avec moi c'est peut-être un
détail parmi d'autres mais si vous
raconte tout ça c'est pour essayer de
vous montrer à quel point à l'époque
faire se tasse sur le terrain dans ces
endroits
c'était d'une violence folle
clairement je savais pertinemment en
allant là bas qu'il y avait des chances
que je revienne pas et donc je me
conditionner mentalement à ne pas avoir
droit à l'erreur dans ma tête j'avais
pas le droit de me retrouver dans une
situation avec mes fixeur où on pouvait
être prise en otage
et si c'était le cas
je préférerais mourir que de me
retrouver dans une vidéo de l'état
islamique du coup je pense y en a
forcément parmi vous qui doivent se dire
pourquoi aller là bas dans ce cas là
parce que je pense sincèrement et
profondément que ce travail
d'information il est primordial parce
qu'on a envie que le monde sache ce
qu'il se passe là bas que les victimes
puissent obtenir justice et qu'on ne les
oublie pas et je pense aussi dans une
certaine mesure que c'est aussi parce
qu'on on a envie ou on espère changer
les choses en tout cas moi c'est ma
vision mon métier je sais pas si on a
tous la même mais je pense qu'on est
quand même beaucoup à le faire pour ça
c'est ce qui explique super bien paul
conroy un photographe qui était avec
marie coll devine quand elle a été tué à
homs et je trouve qu'il a des mots assez
juste pour comprendre pourquoi c'est
aussi important des reporters continue
d'aller sur le terrain
sauf
les 20
juin 2017 mossoul
la capitale irakienne de l'état
islamique est sur le point de tomber
des nuages de fumée noire se dégage des
combats entre les soldats de l'armée
irakienne et les derniers djihadistes de
dèche retranché dans le quartier de la
vieille ville
donc j'arrive à un moment extrêmement
violent de la bataille de mossoul et je
pars directement dans les hôpitaux de la
ville pour filmer les victimes civiles
et militaires de cette guerre
soit intégrée à pied ben
hadid cinq ans et sa soeur ayache à 6
ans ont été blessés par un bombardement
dans mossoul ouest le petit garçon doit
subir une deuxième opération aujourd'hui
il a perdu son oeil il ya une grosse
plaie de globes oculaires et la fa lui
faire une émigration de l'oeil il ya
beaucoup d' image extrêmement difficile
dans ce documentaire mais il y en a
aussi beaucoup que je n'ai pas pu
montrer parce qu'elle était trop dur
trop violentes ou trop triste j'ai des
souvenirs de scènes tellement violente
avec des pères de famille qui arrivait
avec leurs enfants déchiquetés dans les
bras après un bombardement qu'on avait
entendu la violence de certaines
blessures par balles c'était vraiment un
tournage difficile et pourtant j'avais
déjà vu des blessures de guerre en
palestine en afrique mais là avec tout
le contexte que j'aime vous donnez de
l'état islamique je pense que c'était
encore plus traumatisant à vivre et
pourtant c'était plus le début du voyage
en enfer parce que quelques semaines
plus tard je suis parti filmer les
charniers de l'état islamique y tuer les
martyrs et il les aligne est la grande
tendance rapport à red
les ça ce sont les bandeaux pour les
yeux
et on voit bien les trous des balles
chez des taches de sang à
internet
après les avoir exécuté il les jetés
dans le trou ici pour ce documentaire je
suis allé dans plusieurs régions d'irak
et j'ai notamment pu filmer dans le
charnier de spyker qui est sûrement le
plus grand massacre de l'état islamique
en irak ont disparu coeur parce que
c'est le nom d'une ancienne base
américaine dans la ville de tikrit tu
essaies à cet endroit qu'a eu lieu la
tuerie en juin 2010 est en seulement
deux jours l'organisation terroriste a
tué plus de 1700 jeunes soldats de
l'armée irakienne sur les bords du tigre
1700 ça paraît complètement irréel c'est
hyper difficile d'imaginer ce chiffre
dans la réalité et je vais pas vous
montrer les images de ce massacre
puisqu'ils ont tout filmé mais c'était
vraiment un abattoir humains
et j'étais là quand ils ont commencé à
déterrer les corps
vous voyez c'est encore en cours de
décomposition
c'est très dur de découvrir des cadavres
d'enfants dans les charniers
ceux des femmes enceintes qui porte
encore leur foetus
tomber sur des têtes décapitées et
nous devons être très solide et fort il
faut parfois se faire violence pour ne
pas craquer c'est un documentaire qui
m'a beaucoup marqué à l'époque parce que
j'avais vraiment la sensation d'être
allé au bout de l'inhumanité et que je
pourrais pas avoir quelque chose de plus
dur après et quand je suis rentré en
france j'ai eu besoin d'aller voir un
psy pour parler de ce que j'avais vu et
je continue encore d'y aller quand je
vois des choses trop difficile après ça
m'a pas empêché de continuer à
documenter des crimes un peu partout
dans le monde parce que voilà je pense
que c'est important de les dénoncer et
c'est pour ça que quelques mois plus
tard j'étais parti aux philippines pour
parler des nouveaux territoires où
l'état islamique essayé de s'implanter
même ton équipe
on va salée quand les autres vous
couvrez l'arrière couvre l arrière
[Musique]
les tonga rayon pattaya nyon pénale en
audience est ici que la tuerie s'est
produite ce matin
les otages étaient agenouillés
et les bourgs où les habits on nous
arrange
il les avait menotté à l'époque il ils
ont abattu un parent justice y est ça et
ça détend banda puyol en mars 2010neuf
l'état islamique perd la bataille de
baggs sa marque la fin territoriale de
dèche en syrie et quelques mois plus
tard j'ai pu pénétrer dans une des
prisons où était retenu est enfermé la
plupart des djihadistes du groupe
terroriste
à tours 2 c'est passé il garde en
premier
je peux pas m'avancer plus
peut-être ils nous ont expliqué que plus
on va loin dans la salle s'il ya le
moindre problème puis c'est difficile de
revenir vers la porte d'entrée la vidéo
avait fait le tour des réseaux sociaux à
l'époque et j'avais un peu l'impression
d'avoir bouclé la boucle en rencontrant
enfin des membres de cette organisation
qui avait terrorisé le monde
[Musique]
et finalement j'en viens à ce
documentaire que j'ai réalisée en juin
dernier pour boutique ce le stade noir
le stade noir c'était en fait la prison
à jaca des djihadistes de l'état
islamique où il torturait et tuer leur
prisonnier et pendant ce tournage j'ai
eu le sentiment que c'était peut-être la
dernière fois que je travaillais sur
l'organisation terroriste parce que
c'est extrêmement difficile
humainement et
parce que je sais pas si j'ai envie de
revivre en corse a encore des tournages
sur des crimes aussi violent aussi
nullement
quand je suis sorti de prison j'ai dormi
pendant un mois sur les genoux de ma
mère
allait au début je dormais seul et je me
réveillais terrifiée
je les voyais dans mes rêves venir me
chercher et m'ont enlevé à la mosquée ou
à la maison
je suis quand même content d'avoir filmé
ce documentaire de l'avoir fait mais je
pense que la prochaine fois je
retournais dans cette partie du monde
j'aimerais bien que ça soit pour
raconter autre chose voilà j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu elle est un peu
plus long que d'habitude mais je me suis
dit que ça pouvait à vous intéresser
j'ai hâte de vous montrer la suite de ce
que je prépare merci pour votre soutien
et à très vite
[Musique]